l'enseignement de l'occitan dans les
petites classes a le vent en poupe
l'éducation nationale en effet décidé de
créer dès la rentrée prochaine des
classes les primaires français occitan à
albi et à saint-affrique oui mais d'ores
et déjà ce genre d'enseignement existe
grâce à une association
la calandre est acquis à toulouse
pratique le bilinguisme dès l'âge de
deux ans avec en plus
initiation à d'autres langues comme
l'anglais et le russe en cas de gilles
ramon et de christian richard ici pas de
folklore des huées ou de militantisme
occitan la calandrette véritable
laboratoire linguistique se veut avant
tout l'école de la modernité la seule en
tout cas à proposer le bilinguisme
naturel et une calandre est c'est une
école sous contrat avec l'état mais
gérée par une association qui depuis
longtemps a compris l'intérêt du
bilinguisme pour un jeune européen dit
qu'on commence le terme occitan dans
l'esprit de vie publique
ça fait référence à une espèce de
ringardisme de folklorisme d'attache un
peu suranné à des valeurs sûres et
dysphasiques on aimerait retrouver
nous ne nous situons absolument deçà
dans cette optique là nos enfants nous
avons bourreuse l'ambition d'en faire
des jeunes qui seront
tout à fait à l'aise dans les nouvelles
technologies dans le maniement de
plusieurs langues européennes
c'est dès maintenant que les jeunes
oreilles de la calandre elle se
familiarise avec d'autres sonorités
patrimoine culturel commun certes
l'enseignement de l'occitan se définit
d'abord comme le terreau indispensable
avant l'apprentissage ultérieure
d'autres langues
nous faisons pour les enfants du
primaire une initiation à la langue
anglaise et à la langue russe sous forme
de demi journées qui leur sont qui sont
consacrés à l'une ou l'autre langue
notre prétention dans ce domaine c'est
d'ouvrir les enfants à ces cultures qui
sont complètement différentes de celles
de la région et de garder intacte
également toutes les plages sonores de
l'oreille tu fais une expérience parmi
d'autres mais une expérience tout à fait
intéressant s'il ya une calandre est
surtout 12 c'est une école qui est sous
contrat avec l'état et nous devons
suivre ce travail nous ne faisons
d'ailleurs déjà une expérience
passionnante mais qui n'a pourtant pas
encore trouvé une reconnaissance
officielle de la part du ministère de
l'éducation nationale
même si ce dernier vient précisément de
consentir un effort supplémentaire à la
cause de l'occitan dans l'école publique
monsieur ministres éducation nationale
lionel jospin a décidé de montrer tout
son intérêt pour l'enseignement de
l'occitan en accordant des moyens
supplémentaires ont permettant
l'ouverture de deux classes bilingues
line à saint-affrique l'autre albi en
donnant également 30 % d'heures
supplémentaires confuse pour les
enseignants la calandrette risque-t-elle
de disparaître alors même que l'état se
préoccupe enfin de l'occitan un paradoxe
difficile à gérer pour les responsable
toulousain de la calandrette qui
continuent à vivre une situation
financière au bord du gouffre